all right welcome to a new video i'll be
doing a 15-minute game again so i think
i think really good for doing comentarii
playing a highly rated player here to
386 from germany actually let's see if
the name is in them no it isn't and it's
a very new account trying to figure out
okay one in the first two games and
three minutes is on 2,000 okay so maybe
this was a bit lucky for him to to win
the two game is hard to tell very new
account only hope I I have that this is
no no cheating account or something
we'll see obviously I prefer to play
against our players who've got much more
games played already so play can play g3
here on 93 I go 93 of course you can
also go d 4 or other stuff but let's
play without the fianchetto in this game
and now big parting of the ways black
can play Bishop d7 Bishop and all this
now be dias heaven takes on c4p should
be for all kinds of lines so what should
i play now online bd7 Bishop g5 Sam as
possible but I don't know these lines so
well I think I'll go for the exchange
here
ok we'll take back with the pawn and now
I have the child can also play Bishop f4
which sometimes is quite a good idea
i'll try that lets see em what setup is
going to choose Bishop g5 is so the more
common move but Bishop f4 can be really
nice for white if black doesn't do
anything concrete here to take use of
this if I play III here he might go
night to h5 trying to provoke Bishop g5
there should be seven exchanging maybe i
can go h3 here I try h3 preserving this
Bishop if he plays Knight h5 so that i
can drop it back of course this is a bit
slow so maybe he's got ideas to make use
of this like I don't know maybe Bishop
b4 should be 494 Queen f5 trying to use
the spin on the sea 39 this could be an
option for black
of course he can just play am Bishop e7
to continue in normal okay he actually
tries to use this
so interesting now what should I play
they go III my Trillium yeah take use of
the spin
should I consider
maybe Quincy to hear or 94 maybe 92
immediately I'm getting rid of the pin
on Queen a five I would also go 92
hard to tell
if he goes 94 I go Bishop go III then
the screen a five-month really looks a
bit bit bit annoying III 94 Bishop d3
okay I better that I could do this so
queer a fire first Queen a5 e3 94 Bishop
d3 you can can take on 33 this is the
problem okay so he doesn't try to make
use of this immediately and I think I
can just play you three here and I'm
just right in time to get the King out
of the pin if he doesn't use this pin
here on on the night with some immediate
play Queen a5 stuff then I think um this
is ok for me okay so Bishop d3 now you
can go 94 but I'm not sure that this
really is some so great i can just
castle
and he lost quite some time with this
and he don't know he has problems
keeping the night only form
yeah but if it doesn't play 94 this
whole setup didn't didn't make so much
sense really okay okay just pawn takes
all right so that I have c3 to c4 okay
but I don't want to play it immediately
because some Queen f5 might be but
that's just thankful for a moment here
okay no just castling is fine and now
I'd like to play C form but Knight b6
here maybe 9 p-6 this could be an idea
who doesn't really
care about this seems
alright so suffice the attacking his
center if you play something like Bishop
e6 I can I can play rook be one first
and also think about just taking on your
form
and yeah this looks quite nice now
so rugby one right if I take twice only
for yes Bishop c4 discovery on the Queen
and the rook is saying so I cannot win a
pawn but this is a bit a bit of
problem now a black b7 hanging he cannot
really play be success would really
weaken the coincide so much don't think
this is playable and what should he do
Queen d7 maybe 27
then I have 95 ok and this okay
if I take on a 4d takes 92 I'm attacking
the c-4 point twice the best f5a play
Bishop g5 winning an exchange so maybe
Bishop f5 then I could actually play f3
but I'm not maybe not threatening to
take only four really because of this
Bishop f5 pin
okay some tight think about this a bit
more
should I take on d5 let's let's start
with this he has got Bishop t5 though
which is which is bad I mean bad for me
it doesn't really
do so much good for my position
play see 5 also trying to fix this
weakness
not bad
not a bad move what else of them
could also try to try to double on the
beef or maybe this is also good
the only active plane yes is like doing
something on h3 here Queen d7 and
sacrificing but hard to believe so maybe
a move like this come on rugby to
comparing with FB one piling up on on
the beep on but also this rook might
help to to double on the C file like
very flexible i can go Brooke FB one or
rogue c1 rugby c2 if the C file opens up
so um I don't commit to anything here
I'm basically just saying okay you don't
I really have a great move now
another move always
we are thinking of his son Bishop h2 now
he actually provokes me to play this
alright so I dropped the bishop back
need to be cautious always with such a
bishop yo you play played h3 but it's
still a back ring made well this is some
rather rather shocking move f5 it's
really a completely weakening 'if I've I
think this must be must be really bad
okay so first gain this temper here
what now 95 here 95 is a kind of obvious
move what about whom
and on 95 I mean really needs to take I
think as c6 is also hey all right of
course with the bishop and now this is a
beautiful piece here
hmm
not quite sure how he should continue
one thing that I'm may be threatening
really maybe is f3 f3 and picking up f5
I'm not one hundred percent sure because
of the special night 96cm covering a 5
i'm not sure want to take on the six
this all looks bit strange
all right so he's really am thinking
about those sacrifices on f3 are on on
h3r maybe potentially f3 if I player 3
mmm so what should I do now should it
take on d5 if I take on d5 and he
recaptures with the pawn it's just yeah
dead dead position for black I will get
to see file Bishop a 6 this is basically
winning if I kept on d5 and you capture
with the bishop and then I play F 396
still it's still somehow holding
ok but ok this Bishop a Sri is hard to
believe anyway ok so i think my loops
don't have any useful role on the B file
anymore so thats why play with c1
another idea also may be a form a four
and then c5 not a bad positional
maneuver but I think he really calls for
opening the seafoam
in a bit of water i hope this sounds are
not too irritating okay it's taking its
time here
yeah this was possible but
I thought that the sea porn is just too
weak now he can he can play maybe c5 in
some way in some way means i'm not sure
if you can play now at this position we
could maybe take and by taking this not
playable at all we should default maybe
but i can just capture
c5 now who is displayable
John may be safe I've
looks terribly shaky but I'm sure if I
can
uh-huh
I see okay if I take on e6 he wants to
just capture with the rook and this this
way protecting this is six pawn okay
what I'm wondering is if I play f3 here
what is he doing
you can maybe go nigh g5 with with place
hmm
95 yeah but maybe you can do this I was
thinking about f 39 f six and then twin
f5 just taking the pawn and using all
those pins but he can go to g5 strangely
enough I take rook takes really who this
isn't so great
I mean it isn't bad but doesn't look
like to complete some refutation or
something
so what about Bishop b3 there should be
three many attacking c6 and asking him
how Joey I would defend this still see
five possible
another move is a four a five this kind
of stuff hardly sides or
it all looks quite attractive queen bee
three and Roxy to also
come on I need to play a movie on how to
determine for me what what what's really
best here
I want to allow root b2 c2 with the
smooth but maybe there was something
more determined that I could play
yeah tough position what should leg do
he normal-looking move would be king age
eight where it would be a very human
move get rid of this sort of Pena okay
if I play rook see to know he captures I
would actually need to check with the
Queen which is a bit bit ugly looking
I will check with the rookie has got
this 92 stuff
but take only six myself yeah okay can
take with a look as mentioned
okay I just I need to speed up here can
think about this all day I really can
can spend my sweet time on this kind of
positions because it really calls for
accurate play if y plus accurately here
we will certainly enjoy an advantage but
you can you can easily spoil this
an advantage just because this bishop
only five should be stronger than this
night whatever he is about to try the
bishop will be the better piece most
most probably
yeah if it takes now I need to take what
the Queen rook takes 92 is quite
embarrassing wow what a strange move
yeah strange because um this is a sort
of point you could just take yeah
because of the pin that's it looks very
very weird to play this okay but I
cannot simply I cannot use it at the
moment and think
okay so let's let's grab now
and then see how to how to continue
Quinn a for maybe just Queen a four
the c5 an idea irritates me and this
would really prevent it
okay let's play this
I'm not so sure that I really threatened
this this rook c6 you might have a weird
move like 95
I mean just imagine zero move for black
I take and then 95 then my Ruca somehow
disconnected from the c1 rook so I'm not
so sure that I'm really threatening the
spawn
he decided to to coverage anyway
yeah not so easy to make progress
looking quite nicely but don't see em
don't see how to improve this
some other idea need to combine the
summer
okay I'm trying something here
the idea is actually queen e to to f3 or
h5 trying to combine play on the
queenside I'm sorry with them was trying
on the Kings side here his is a big week
weakened here f5 h5 and so on maybe I'm
combining this what would help one idea
actually that he can play it could play
dough doesn't move before it's 95 I take
with the porn Wookiee five but I have at
least rook takes d5 was very nice
compensation for the exchange okay so he
actually went c5 but he's in a pin here
so okay let's prove let's fix those
pawns
and then see how to make progress here
case piling up on this this bishop
I don't mind him to take
I go a five feet will have be five which
is really nothing that I can can like
very much maybe clearly five
first don't mind him exchanging then I
can switch to the a file and the tech a
7
if you move the Queen I will play a five
I will play a 50 K his idea could be
rook g6 yeah Luke g6 but the rookies
hanging am only age so he cannot play
rook g6 at the moment nigeria could he
could try and I still there is no
checkmate should g3 art song
co k move the king so let's grab him
now try to
Quincy for my take play b5 don't want
bad how weakening sf3 actually
okay want to get rid of the night here
and play Quincy for next
yeah went down really down on time but
he's not speeding up as well
DRA offered no no
I still should should be a bit better
here I'm not entirely mistaken
I have those though central points here
especially now after he took this should
be worth something
King III coming and then if I change one
rook these pawns really should should
win the game
just here right
and then look c6 coming and his son is
really slow here so this is a nexus 6
yeah she still should be okay
okay I'll take it
don't mind to take the pawn area
black resigns yeah ok so a very
difficult game like put up some some
tough resistance here we don't look in
noise all noise for Wyatt but it's not
not entirely clear how how I should
progress let me let me quickly go
through this just just briefly
this is all very nice for white but f5
really looked like
we had to wait decision you know maybe
where r c 5 volt so as an idea pending
on pinning down on the beep on the the
problem that i have with c5 is playing
on the queenside fe at one point mayor
just to get his rook into play so let's
say here and he manages to get this rook
somewhere else like hear ya and then
bishop c8 back then the single bishop
protecting it looks passive yeah but the
single bishop is protecting basically
his only weakness and then he can play
on the King side the thing is if i play
c5 i might need to play on the kingside
myself playing 95 and then f 3g for
stuff like this year night here f 3g for
so c5 is not really designed to attack
on the queenside just to close the tea
and then open here maybe c5 would have
been better okay this is not not like
not late great for black or anything
it's it's still better for wild
yeah this all look pretty normal to me
ok now I'm probing around a bit here
this is maybe not not the best kind of
continuation actually the computer wants
to play all these moves I here once a
player 3 uh-huh ok maybe because 96 is
not so great
nobody five looked looked very very
normal take shake
yet the computer actually assesses this
position is equal but I'm sure after
this okay and only a slight advantage
too wide what taking us taking as a
problem yeah I was surprised that he
took here in this kind of position I can
never really take on c5 because I would
give would give up a five so if you
place a normal move maybe this even I
can I cannot take really because I Lucy
five so in this kind of configuration
it's hard for me to make progress I can
try okay one look somewhere a six or
something but it's not like i can i can
make meg you chure it wants us here and
in the position but you help me with
taking okay i guess what's a little time
it proved to be difficult and this is
now we have computer already on +1
something these pawns are too strong
they are just too strong
yeah this is really over I can just pull
those through oh okay he's cubed saying
he had the opponent or he or she it's
actually a female name here Melinda um
he's some writing to me chatting to me
if I'm commenting alright so so let's
let's finish this video here pretty
interesting fight um up until the end
like really held its own maybe c5 would
have been better at this in this
position to keep on here to keep the
queenside close and then switch over to
the Kings side so um maybe this was was
better and I'm referring to this kind of
position here playing c5 here instead of
rupee one alright thanks for watching
another interesting Rapids term control
game again I think and talk to you soon
in a new video